all right 300 to 1 actually hey guys
welcome to just kidding news under skin
you [ __ ] justice for dogs news submitted
by well let's do the scumbag guy who
submit this particular guy's a scumbag
mum Cheers as son is jailed for beating
dog to death with month the mom is happy
that the son went to jail because I
raised them right
this dude is such a scum magnet even as
mom's like yeah [ __ ] that dude oh like
that she cheered for him to be like to
beat that dogs it's like a dog fight
it's like I raised them John McLoughlin
26 savagely punched 11 month year old
Lika Alice Alice Alice it's a dog yeah
like we're just gonna call this dog
Lexie to death before dumping her body
near some trees which traumatized
children who found it what oh [ __ ] oh my
god for reals so he was jailed for 16
weeks and his sibling says that that
wasn't long and I'd agree I think he
tracked it back cuz when he like threw
the dog there that he just left the
collar on and everything
probably a proper dumbass of punching a
dog in the face yeah at the same time so
here well actually I'm not gonna show a
picture of this scum no please do yeah
here's a picture of that
big George that's a big-ass [ __ ] dog
this is this is a picture they're all
gonna survive No oh that's a picture of
the dead got the dead dog cute ass dog I
know right look at how look at how good
of a boy no right yeah so that
apparently he just had he only owned it
for a like yeah for a little bit before
he in a fit of rage punched it to death
which I'm like thank you what the [ __ ]
like what the hell how does one like I
hear are people like losing their their
[ __ ] sense of everything in like a
blind rage but like that's pretty
[ __ ] crazy you were you acid hunt you
beat something to do gotta get help at
that point yeah for reals dude so
because he did that he dumped it yeah
people found it and initially he told
police that all we got hit by a car and
then he eventually fest up to it once
obviously wasn't hit by a car this size
all here and it's [ __ ] face yeah so
yeah so he went to jail and his mom
children for that yeah so fact this guy
and this guy's a [ __ ] scum does this
guy 2066
know first of all how do you punch a dog
that be dead yeah that's intense
but since I've imagined that [ __ ]
like family mm-hm
we're like your son goes to jail for
whatever he's in and the moms like yeah
it's not long enough no that's not long
enough dad like the kind of family that
raised this monster yeah it's kind of
weird kind of [ __ ] up right like yeah
what I wonder what else he did growing
up if that point but the mom is so what
happened to him
like to the point where like the parent
is just so over there's kids [ __ ] that
they're like yeah he deserved what we
should've cut he should have gone to
jail for longer yeah environment with
you raised in yeah you gotta you gotta
kind of wonder like what does this have
family life like where they're all just
like yeah [ __ ] this scumbag you know
yeah and it's funny cuz like usually I'm
not in super agreement with PETA's as a
group but Peter was like you know this
dude's kind of dangerous like the fact
that he's able to punch a dog did
nothing means he's a danger to Canadian
I was like
you know your dad you know what you're
right you're right that's a baby dog
that's two things that you should never
punch
oh oh oh my god yeah now I'm really
think is like well what does his family
do to him that wants to lash out on a
dog no yeah but at the same time he
could be just like that in celle type of
mentality thing we're like he separates
himself from people and he blames other
people for how you say I feel like you
get to a certain plate like I feel like
people are a product of their
environment but no one is just like this
[ __ ] crazy I mean unless they're like
like mentally like gone right well if
they are just a terrible person I feel
like it's a product product of like
whatever they grew up in like I don't
know you could be the black sheep like I
could so yeah you see he could be this
the weird one in the family or whatever
Bay and they let him know he's weird so
it's like even further weird he pled
guilty to the charge but I mean you
could argue that it's like yeah there's
not a whole lot of ways he could
probably have gotten out of me you know
if he applied any other way but he pled
guilty and he does say that he regrets
and he feels bad for what he did no it
does that no you gotta get for being
yeah I don't know if that's also the
lawyers saying hey he's like yeah like
my client does feel a lot of remorse for
doing it here do you do this oh yeah
dude so Suri's imagine if he didn't say
it either like yeah that dog deserved it
there are some people though they're
like well [ __ ] it double down on being
an [ __ ] and just feel like yeah
[ __ ] I were to do it again I wonder
if it's considered oh I guess not a
felony because his prison is really in
the u.s. in the u.s. he is now treated
as a felon but I don't know in the UK
you think he always watch scooby-doo and
he related with the criminals he should
have gotten away with it too don't know
anybody that was ever angry at Scooby
I hate that show why is cuz it's like
you know repetitive and the story
structures like dead damn dog stories
way deeper than it goes right
maybe it's parents were criminals and
every time you would watch it scooby-doo
and a Saturday morning his pants would
be like oh these kids and that dog
routing that good honest man's was a
little like a wave of like a Croatian
his life he's going up and he's like
yeah that dog yeah or what if they got
Freaky Friday like what if what if like
the dog always hated the kid and the kid
loved the dog so then they got switched
and the dogs I know is now the chopper
the kid and then he beat the dog and
that's killing the child he's like I'm
not going back he's just like it now I
have thumbs
he's like you deny me bows on the table
okay it's mine now you're making me beg
for scraps like an animal if there was
ever a switching of the thing like that
the dog would forever go around just
like this and just be like this is
amazing just only do things with this
thumb where are my testicles summer and
then I fall think he's like I can't
clean myself anymore like Twilight Zone
any sort of [ __ ]
all this time no bollock I finally have
balls but I can no longer crazy dude I
mean I feel like most of the like pet
owners that I know are pretty
responsible though like I don't know I
don't know anybody that has like been
straight-up abusive to their dog thank
[ __ ] god just like I'm trying to
imagine like the kind of people that
have report them or something yeah like
I can't imagine like I mean I definitely
owe people that is like yeah probably
haven't taken as good care of the dog is
like they probably should have but I
don't think was ever malicious yeah it's
kind of like sometimes it could be
better with how they treat them but yeah
but it's also not like they're like
actively like beating yeah yeah no but
then you got the other side of the
spectrum where they treat them like like
a child oh yeah they're really shitty
like they're really shitty dogs or a
really shitty man yeah dude yeah [ __ ]
all right siblings friend would get
carbides from like her friend's mom and
I guess like this mom was really really
into like her dogs because I do treat
her exactly like kids and I guess like
they're running like 30 minutes late at
the mall or whatever and she's like we
need to go now I told our little doggies
at home that will be home at this time
and I'm pretty sure they're freaking out
right now
and then at that point I'm just kind of
like just sleep in there like I'm gonna
leave hello yeah but I mean I feel like
yeah I definitely haven't seen a lot of
dogs that are just like man y'all have a
good year way to coddle mica holy [ __ ]
like this dog like owns you you know
quit looking at me when you say it okay
I do not coddle tipsy
yeah definitely I'm like you're my son
yeah but you also you're my son who's a
dog I promise you this but I'm sorry son
but also I don't feel like you call him
Riley I don't feel like you are like you
know I you know like I'm in a blanket my
son who I realize is a dog yeah you also
need to like set boundaries and stuff
like you feed peas in the house or
something you're not quite gonna be like
oh that's just Friday or whatever
ideally my kid who also be in the house
I'd be like hey don't do that
yeah exactly that's I mean like some
people would just be like Oh what do you
do this you need to like Tom it's unless
it's like my fault then I'm like it's
okay then you start apologizing
difference though or like something I'm
like I know I did a bad I'm a bad dog I
like hearing about tipsy and like
stories at tipsy cuz I just remember a
Devin came over here unlike after JK
news and it was a nighttime and he was
like oh [ __ ] I forgot to tell him to
light and I was like light at home and
he was like yeah yeah yeah for my dog
and I was like okay I mean like I mean
it's reasonable right but like I just
didn't know that it was like such a huge
like thing yeah good I feel like she's
also pretty old yeah like now now
apparently the vet says like we should
keep it like we should have a light on
for tipsy like a night light yeah like
what do you mean he's fine boiling them
that's not like well the thing is in
Julia's story this is well he was
younger and the reason is then you have
no excuse yeah my dog gets angry and
thing is it's angry and this is the part
that I don't like that's good tips he's
incredibly smart when he's angry you
only told me is angry because he'll be
like little eyebrows yeah weird like
you'll see these dark lines in like 30
just like his dad yeah so uh big dogs
are just like their owners yeah but yeah
like there's a one time I forgot what I
did that made tipsy mad but he looked at
the shoes I'd been wearing for the past
week
pooped all the way in the toe of it
so you couldn't see them together so I
got the poop pick up the shoe shook it
now apparently and the only reason I
even found out is because I was wearing
my brother's metal on at the time and my
brother comes he's like so uh Devon I
worried you shoot today no he went did
you piss off tipsy I was like I think so
why is like there's poop in my shoe you
know my feet now
gypsy picked it up with his thumb he's
been hiding thumbs this entire time he
only pulls it out but he's like really
angry is like Wolverine this is like
this will hurt a lot but it's work if
you saw the footage of him escaping from
the [ __ ] yep roll that [ __ ] yeah see
is [ __ ] scary dangerous like he never
needs to get this video so I could put
that [ __ ] in there
excuse me what are you doing
well really really [ __ ] terrifying
man I watched this dog escape from a
[ __ ] cage it was like watching them
some like [ __ ] it was like watching a
dog break out of Alcatraz what the hell
what the hell it's really cute but the
the the night that that happened you you
went home and you texted me I was like
yeah tipsy got out of his room and he
completely knocked down the trash and he
like just rummage through everything I
remember this do not forget Houdini dog
I would literally I would lock him in a
room as in literally shut the door and I
would lock the physical door and I will
come out and he's as like in the living
room chilled on the couch just looked at
me with a smile first of all I live
alone
second of all I'd go and I check the
door it still locks it just dumb dude
get out and then he picked it to lock it
again he's just like sitting there just
like remember this lock pick one honey I
know where you sleep yeah and now
reminds me to when he used to get mad
cuz I'd be up late at night editing news
and he went to sleep what he would do is
then when I had school or something in
the morning I'd be starting to wake up
and I'd feel like a pressure like go on
my chest I would look and he starts
climbing on my chest and cuts off just
enough air knocked me back y'all so he
could go back to see I'm like no just
remember all it takes is a couple more
pounds of pressure and again this is
what tipsy looks like there yeah that's
right insert a picture I'll give you
this one add it then I don't know
anymore what if she was like a
reincarnation of like some Satan
I don't think maybe like some sort of
serial killer but maybe not really a
serial killer because I was liking
killing anything but he's the yin to my
yang
[Music]